student busted for selling pills through
the mail federal prosecutors say this
college student sold drugs using the
postal service it is a topic the 8 news
now i-team has investigated for months
our own david charns here in studio with
an exclusive interview with drug agents
brian prosecutors say this college
student also sold drugs when he was in
high school leading to two overdose
deaths as we have told you illicit
fentanyl is killing unsuspecting users
with deaths right here in the valley
above 200 last year and now
investigators say this unlv college
student was mailing drugs from the post
office federal investigators say
surveillance images from a las vegas
post office show 21-year-old colin
sheppard mailing pills to a middleman in
utah an undercover informant telling the
drug enforcement administration that
shepard sold him or her fake oxycodone
pills like these in bulk court documents
include photos like this one a priority
mail envelope with as many as 35 pills
inside the return address to colin
sheppard on unlv's campus because the
dark web doesn't have boundaries it can
oftentimes be global in nature the 80s
now i-team has previously spoken to the
dea about shipping drugs through the
mail using the dark web it's a network
of servers requiring a special app to
access just a plain google search isn't
going to get you there court documents
indicate shepard claimed the pills he
was selling were pharmaceutical grade
quote they're a bit pricey as they are
presses but they are from canada so
thanks to free health care they aren't
crazy expensive we want to help as much
as we can to work with the public and
get information out to people so we can
help prevent things prosecutors allege
an 18-year-old in utah overdosed after
buying shepherd's pills surveillance
photos from february showing shepard
mailing the pills to that victim here in
another case shepard is accused of
mailing pills to an undercover agent
when that agent didn't immediately
respond shepard appeared to become
worried prosecutors providing these text
messages
sorry about being so worried just
wanting to check in and make sure you
weren't dead as it's never a good sign
when someone goes m.i.a after getting an
expletive ton of opiates
shepard was prosecuted in the juvenile
system and sentenced to probation for
those two earlier cases in this latest
case prosecutors say the student used
encrypted apps to talk to potential
buyers right now he's being detained
pending a court hearing that's happening
later this month i'm david charns live
local now